Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
Herjavec: OH, COOL.
WHOO!
WE BECAME THE MOST CROWDFUNDED
TRAVEL CAMPAIGN IN HISTORY.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHOO-HOO-HOO!
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
THE PROBLEM IS --
WAIT, I DON'T NEED YOUR
BUP-BUP-BUP!
STICK TO YOUR BASKETBALL.
PLEASE, DON'T BE RUDE.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
WHY IS IT WORTH
$28 MILLION?
...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THAT I'VE
EVER SEEN OUT THERE LIKE IT.
WE WANT THE RIGHT PARTNER.
YOU HAVE NOTHING!
NOTHING!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A GROWN-UP VERSION
OF A CHILDHOOD FAVORITE.
WHOO!
Herjavec: COOL.
Corcoran: WOW.
[ CHUCKLES ]
THAT JUST HAPPENED.
SHARKS,
MY NAME IS TYLER HADZICKI,
MY COMPANY
IS LEAUX RACING TRIKES,
AND I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING
$120,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
I'VE BEEN WANTING TO SPIN
INTO THE TANK LIKE THAT
FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT'S THE KIND
OF EXCITEMENT YOU GET
WHEN YOU RIDE ONE OF MY TRIKES.
IT'S LIKE A RACECAR
AND A TRICYCLE HAD A LOVE CHILD.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WITH THREE WHEELS,
NOT ONLY DO YOU GET
STABILITY AND SPEED,
BUT INCREDIBLE AGILITY, AS WELL.
THE REAR WHEELS ARE CASTERS
THAT CAN BE CONTROLLED MANUALLY
WITH THIS HANDLE TO TAKE
TIGHT CORNERS, DRIFT,
AND EVEN SPIN 360 DEGREES.
SHARKS, THIS IS NOT
JUST AN ADULT TRICYCLE,
THIS IS AN EXPERIENCE
UNLIKE ANYTHING ELSE OUT THERE.
I'M READY TO TAKE THIS
TO THE WORLD.
NOW, WHO WANTS TO COME ALONG
FOR THIS CRAZY RIDE?
I GOT TO TRY IT.
IS THERE ANY CERTAIN AGE
FOR IT?
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING, LORI?
YOUNG AT HEART.
I HAVE TWO MORE BACK HERE.
OH, COME ON, MARK.
I'LL RACE YOU.
KEVIN, JOIN THEM.
YOU HAVE ONE
BIG ENOUGH FOR MARK?
OF COURSE.
THESE ARE FULLY ADJUSTABLE.
I GOT A BIG-ASS HEAD.
THEY STILL DON'T FIT.
[ LAUGHS ]
THEY'RE NOT BUMPER CARS.
THEY ARE NOW.
OH!
OOH.
KEVIN, YOU'RE THE ONLY GUY
THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE RIDING
A LITTLE TRICYCLE.
SPEED UP.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THEY'RE SUPER DURABLE.
YOU CAN CRASH INTO EACH OTHER.
OH, MY GOD.
OH!
[ LAUGHS ]
THERE YOU GO, MARK.
PERFECT.
WA-HOO-HOO!
OH!
HOW DID YOU WIPE OUT?
[ SIGHS ]
[ LAUGHS ]
I LOVED IT.
LORI,
YOU GOT TO TRY IT.
I'D LOVE TO TRY IT.
I'M IN A SKIRT.
NOT SO EASY
ON THE BUMPS.
THAT WAS COOL.
TYLER,
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
YOU'RE SO LOW,
YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE GOING
A MILLION MILES AN HOUR.
LEAUX RACING TRIKES.
RIGHT.
THEY'RE SO LOW.
DID YOU CREATE THIS
YOURSELF?
SO, THIS STARTED OFF
A LONG TIME AGO,
AS A 6th-GRADE SCIENCE PROJECT.
THE TEACHER HATED THE IDEA
BECAUSE IT WASN'T
"SCIENTIFIC" ENOUGH.
BUT THEN WHEN I WON FIRST PLACE
AT THE SAN DIEGO SCIENCE FAIR,
I GUESS SHE HAD TO EAT IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER YOU WON THE AWARD?
WELL, I HAVE THE FIRST PICTURE
OF THE ORIGINAL TRICYCLE HERE,
AND WHAT I DID WAS
I WENT TO THE SWAP MEET,
AND I WAS CUTTING UP TRIKES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, THAT'S PROTOTYPE ONE.
THAT'S PROTOTYPE ONE.
THAT WON A SCIENCE FAIR.
YOU'VE IMPROVED IT A LOT.
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE TO GO FROM
THERE TO THIS?
ABOUT FOUR YEARS.
ARE YOU IN COLLEGE?
I'M A SOPHOMORE IN COLLEGE.
NOW YOU TRY TO BRING IT
TO MARKET.
KICKSTARTER --
A CROWD-FUNDING PLATFORM.
WHAT WAS YOUR TARGET?
MY TARGET WAS $15,000.
RAISED $46,000, SO 300% OF MY
GOAL, WHICH WAS PRETTY COOL.
THERE WAS 130 ORDERS.
I PRODUCED THOSE
ALL AT MY FACILITY.
I GOT THOSE SHIPPED OUT
OVER THAT YEAR.
WHERE'S YOUR FACILITY?
WE WENT TO MEXICO
AND SET UP A FACILITY THERE
WITH SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
BUILDING BMX BIKES FOR A WHILE.
SO I'M AN INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESSMAN UNDER THE AGE OF 18
WITH THREE PATENTS
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
[ CHUCKLES ]
GOOD FOR YOU.
AND WHAT DID YOU CHARGE
PER UNIT?
WHAT WAS YOUR COST?
THESE ARE $350.
COST ON THESE
IS ABOUT $170-$180 TO MAKE IT.
THESE ARE PRETTY MUCH HAND MADE.
WHAT I DON'T LIKE IS,
I DON'T LIKE MAKING
A WHOLE BUNCH OF THESE,
BECAUSE I HAND-TEST
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
SO YOU WERE NERVOUS.
I GO DOWN TO MEXICO.
I HAVE TO SPEND, YOU KNOW,
EIGHT HOURS A DAY
TESTING A BATCH OF 40.
THAT'S HOW I DO THEM.
OH, SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE
AN INSPECTOR.
RIDE THEM ALL, PACK THEM ALL,
MAKE SURE THIS PAINT'S
POWDER COATED CORRECTLY --
I DON'T WANT ANY BAD PRODUCTS
GOING TO THE CUSTOMER,
'CAUSE IT REFLECTS POORLY ON ME.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA SELL
10,000 OF THESE?
I CAN RENT THE LARGER FACILITY,
THEN I CAN HIRE THE LABOR.
THERE ARE FACILITIES
IN MEXICO AND IN ASIA
THAT MAKE MILLIONS OF BIKES.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU SIMPLY
GO TO ONE OF THEM
AND SAY, "LOOK, I WANT TO GET
10,000 OF THESE MADE BY YOU."
WELL, AN EASY THING, THOUGH,
IS YOU CAN HIRE AN INSPECTOR.
THERE ARE SEVERAL
VERY CREDIBLE SERVICES
LIKE BUREAU VERITAS...
RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT,
DEFINITELY.
...WHERE THEY CAN GO DOWN,
HAVE A PROTOCOL,
AND THEY CAN'T SHIP
UNTIL THOSE ARE CHECKED
AND THE INSPECTION'S DONE.
DEFINITELY, DEFINITELY.
NO, ALL THESE THINGS
ARE COMING IN PLACE.
O'Leary:
IS THERE A DEMAND FOR TENS --
NO, BUT LET HIM SPEAK
A MOMENT.
BUT I NEED -- I WANT TO TEST
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
WHY?
Corcoran: YOU DON'T
WANT TO LET THAT GO.
YOU WANT TO BE
PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR EACH AND EVERY BIKE.
THAT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT IT'S A NICHE --
IT'S A NICHE PRODUCT
BUT YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
AT THIS POINT
THAT I'M ABLE TO.
THEN YOU GOT TO RAISE
YOUR PRICE SIGNIFICANTLY.
RIGHT.
TYLER,
LET ME ASK YOU THIS --
LET ME UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHO BUYS THESE.
IT'S USUALLY
PARENTS FOR THEIR KIDS,
WHICH ARE, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
9 TO 16, AROUND THERE.
AND THEN ALSO
IT'S THE ADULT GUY, KIND OF.
ROBERT.
I THINK YOU'RE A TERRIFIC KID --
OH, MAN, I SHOULD SAY.
YOU LOVE YOUR PRODUCT,
BUT I DON'T SEE
THIS AS INVESTABLE.
IT'S VERY EARLY
IN THE GAME.
I THINK YOU HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO
BEFORE YOU GET
AN INVESTMENT.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION, BARBARA.
ALL RIGHT, LOOK, TYLER.
I-I DON'T SEE THIS
AS AN INVESTMENT FOR ME,
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW I'D
TURN THIS INTO A HUGE BUSINESS.
I'M NOT SURE YOU KNOW YET.
BUT I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, KEVIN,
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
TYLER, YOU ARE A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF AN ENTREPRENEUR.
ONE OF THE THINGS I FIND
VERY ADMIRABLE
IS THAT YOU WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING WAS PERFECT.
ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT,
THOUGH, YOU'RE ONE PERSON.
YOU CAN'T GO
AND STAND IN THE FACTORY
AND WATCH 40 MADE AT A TIME.
I PERSONALLY SEE IT
AS A LICENSING DEAL,
BECAUSE I DO THINK,
TO SCALE, YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A BIG COMPANY
THAT CAN DO EXACTLY THAT.
RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S
A BIT OF A WAYS AWAY.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
TYLER, INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE
FOR ANYBODY AT ANY AGE.
AT YOUR AGE, DOUBLY IMPRESSIVE
WHERE YOU'VE GOTTEN.
NO ONE DOUBTS YOU.
I DOUBT WHAT THE MARKET IS.
IF IT'S A TRICYCLE,
YOU'VE GOT TO CHANGE THE DESIGN.
IT'S TOO HARD-CORE FOR GENERAL
DISTRIBUTION FOR KIDS TO USE.
IF IT'S NICHE,
FOR HARD-CORE PEOPLE LIKE ME
THAT LOVE SPEED, OR OLDER KIDS,
IT'S TOO CHEAP.
I DON'T KNOW HOW BIG
THAT MARKET IS.
BUT I THINK THERE'S
LOADS OF TOYS IN THIS SPACE
THAT ARE THE KID-FRIENDLY,
RIDE-IT-IN-YOUR-DRIVEWAY
KIND OF THING,
AND I THINK IT FITS THERE.
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
A BRILLIANT GUY.
YOU'RE GONNA INVENT
SOMETHING ELSE.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS ONE
FITS OR HOW I CAN HELP YOU.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
Cuban: WHAT'S
YOUR NEXT PRODUCT, TYLER?
MY NEXT PRODUCT?
THE REASON I ASKED
ABOUT WHAT'S NEXT...
MM-HMM.
...IS THIS --
I DON'T SEE THIS AS, YOU KNOW,
SELLING TWO MILLION UNITS.
YEAH.
DEFINITELY.
RIGHT?
SO IF I'M INVESTING
IN YOUR COMPANY,
THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOMETHING NEXT,
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
THE INVESTMENT
SO WE CAN GET
SOMEPLACE ELSE TOGETHER --
SOMEPLACE BIGGER AND BETTER.
SO, I THINK THERE'S LOTS
OF STUFF THAT YOU CAN DO WITH,
YOU KNOW, ADD-ONS, ALL THAT
CUSTOMIZATION KINDS OF THINGS.
THOSE WILL INCREASE YOUR
BUSINESS ON THE MARGIN.
THAT'S NOT GONNA TAKE YOU
TO A $25 MILLION COMPANY.
I MEAN, THE SCOOTER SELLS
SEVEN MILLION UNITS IN ONE YEAR.
ONE YEAR.
BUT THAT APPLIES
TO EVERYBODY.
AND IT GETS YOU FROM POINT "A"
TO POINT "B", AND IT'S FUN.
TYLER, LOOK,
I THINK IT'S BRILLIANT.
BUT I-I HAVE TO SEE
A VISION FROM YOU, RIGHT,
THAT TAKES IT SO IT CAN BE
A MUCH BIGGER COMPANY.
BUT, FOR RIGHT NOW,
I DON'T SEE IT, TYLER.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
BRILLIANT IDEA, THOUGH.
THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA SELL
A LOT ON MY WEBSITE
AND TO THE BIG BOX,
SO THAT'S FINE.
WE HOPE YOU DO.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Corcoran: THANK YOU.
I'M A LITTLE BUMMED THAT
THEY COULDN'T SEE MY VISION.
I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S A TOY,
AND THE FACT THAT THEY WOULDN'T
EVEN CONSIDER OR LISTEN
TO WHAT I HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THE MARKET
WAS JUST RUDE, ALMOST.
JUST RUDE. [ CHUCKLES ]
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A COMPANY
SEEKING TO BRING THE LATEST
BEAUTY TRENDS TO AMERICA.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS SARAH LEE.
AND I'M CHRISTINE CHANG.
AND WE'RE FROM NEW YORK CITY.
WE'RE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF GLOW RECIPE,
AND TODAY WE'RE SEEKING
$425,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR
10% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
GLOW RECIPE IS HERE TODAY
TO MAKE EVERY
AMERICAN WOMAN'S SKIN GLOW
AND MAKE EVERYONE
LOOK BEAUTIFUL
BY BRINGING ONLY THE BEST
PRODUCTS AND SKIN SECRETS
FROM THE MODERN EPICENTER
OF ADVANCED SKIN INNOVATION --
KOREA.
SHARKS, DID YOU KNOW,
IN THE LAST YEAR,
THE TOP U.S. BEAUTY EDITORS
AND MEDIA OUTLETS
HAVE BEEN
CROWNING KOREAN BEAUTY
TO BE 12 YEARS AHEAD
OF THE REST OF THE WORLD?
WITH GLOW RECIPE, KOREAN BEAUTY
IS NO LONGER A HIDDEN SECRET.
WE BELIEVE
THAT KOREAN BEAUTY
CAN BE THE NEXT BIG PLAYER
IN THE U.S.
NOW, WE KNOW THAT BEING
A SHARK ISN'T EASY.
YOU'RE STRESSED,
SLEEP-DEPRIVED,
DEALING WITH THE PRESSURES
OF BEING AN APEX PREDATOR...
[ LAUGHS ]
WE WANTED BRING A LITTLE BIT
OF GLOW INTO YOUR DAY
AND ON TO YOUR FACES,
SO WE HAVE SOME SAMPLES FOR YOU.
I HOPE IT'S WHISKEY.
[ LAUGHS ]
OKAY.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
Herjavec:
THANK YOU, LADIES.
THANK YOU.
MR. WONDERFUL.
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
Chang: SO, THE FIRST
IS A WATERLESS MIST
THAT IS PACKED WITH BOTANICAL
EXTRACTS FOR EXTRA EFFICACY.
PERFECT FOR
ON-THE-GO, 24/7 SKIN CARE --
ESPECIALLY PERFECT FOR SHARKS
THAT NEVER STOP SWIMMING.
OH, IT'S NICE.
SECOND IS PRESSED SERUM.
THIS IS A NEW CATEGORY
IN BEAUTY
THAT COMBINES
THE CONCENTRATION OF A SERUM
AND THE COMFORTING HYDRATION
OF A MOISTURIZER.
SO THIS MULTI-TASKER
IS PACKED WITH
CHAGA MUSHROOM EXTRACT,
WHICH IS ANTI-AGING.
OH, IT FEELS FUNNY.
IT'S LIKE A HALFWAY BETWEEN
A GEL AND A CREAM.
EXACTLY.
YEAH, IT'S WEIRD.
SO, LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
THIS IS THE NEXT GENERATION
SEA-KELP SHEET MASK.
AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD,
SHEET MASKS ARE ON FIRE
IN THE U.S., AND YOU MIGHT HAVE
SEEN THE COTTON SHEET MASKS.
YEAH, I KNEW THAT.
OF COURSE.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, SHARKS, WE WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO JOIN US
ON OUR JOURNEY TO MAKING
THE WORLD MORE BEAUTIFUL...
AND GLOW WITH US.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, LADIES.
YOU DON'T MAKE THESE PRODUCTS.
YOU SOURCE THEM IN KOREA
AND YOU BRING THEM
TO THE UNITED STATES.
EXACTLY.
WE'RE AN E-RETAILER. YES.
YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY
A DISTRIBUTOR.
SO, OUR BUSINESS
IS IN TWO VERTICALS.
ONE IS AN E-COMMERCE SITE,
WHERE WE CURATE THE NATURAL
BEAUTY SKIN CARE PRODUCTS
FROM KOREA.
OH, YOU'RE A CURATOR.
WE CURATE THEM
BASED ON OUR EXPERTISE.
WE HAVE 20-PLUS YEARS
OF COMBINED EXPERIENCE
IN THE WORLD'S LARGEST
BEAUTY COMPANY -- L'ORéAL.
YOU HAVE 20-PLUS YEARS?
COMBINED.
SO, YOU MUST HAVE
HUGE SALES,
BECAUSE YOU'RE PUTTING
A VALUE ON YOUR BUSINESS
OF OVER $4 MILLION.
SO...
LET'S HEAR ABOUT
THOSE SALES.
LAST YEAR, WE OPENED
GLOW RECIPE IN NOVEMBER.
FOR THE FIRST TWO MONTHS,
OUR REVENUE WAS $3,000.
2015, YEAR-TO-DATE,
WE'RE AT $550,000.
WOW.
AND WE'RE PROJECTED TO DO
$1 MILLION
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SO, SARAH,
ALL THOSE SALES ARE ONLINE.
SO, HALF OF THAT COMES FROM
OUR E-COMMERCE SITE,
WHERE WE CURATE THE PRODUCTS.
THE SECOND IS WHERE
WE ACT AS A BRAND INCUBATOR.
SO, OUR SITE --
AND YOU CHARGE THEM
FOR THAT SERVICE?
YES. WE SHARE THE REVENUE
WITH THE BRANDS.
BUT HOW DO PEOPLE KNOW THIS?
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF IT BEFORE.
OF COURSE, SO,
A BIG PART OF OUR PLATFORM
IS TO NOT ONLY CURATE,
BUT ALSO EDUCATE.
WE HAVE
AN EXTREMELY DETAILED SITE
WITH WITH VERY DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS, USAGE, EVEN VIDEO.
OUR MAIN FOCUS RIGHT NOW
IS REALLY ROBUSTLY GROWING
OUR YouTube CHANNEL.
'CAUSE WE REALLY THINK VIDEO --
HOW MANY SUBSCRIBERS?
SO, RIGHT NOW,
OUR SUBSCRIBER BASE
IS STILL AROUND 1,000
BECAUSE WE JUST STARTED,
BUT OUR CUMULATIVE VIEWS
ARE 200,000 RIGHT NOW.
AND WE JUST STARTED.
YEAH, BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY --
THAT'S NOT REALLY
A LEGIT NUMBER THOUGH, RIGHT?
WE JUST STARTED, THOUGH.
EVERYBODY -- RIGHT.
WHY IS KOREA A HOTBED
OF BEAUTY PRODUCTS?
IT'S JUST
HYPER-SPEED INNOVATION.
THE MARKET
IS SO COMPETITIVE LOCALLY.
THE C.E.O. OF ESTEE LAUDER
LIKENED KOREAN'S
BEAUTY INFLUENCE
TO THE INFLUENCE OF PARIS
IN FASHION.
HOW MANY SKEWS DO YOU HAVE?
HOW MUCH INVENTORY DO YOU HAVE?
SO, RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE 110 SKEWS.
WE HAVE 110.
OKAY, SO THAT'S WHERE
YOUR CASH IS GOING THEN, RIGHT?
'CAUSE IF NEW PRODUCTS
ARE COMING OUT ALL THE TIME...
YES.
...YOU'RE -- YOU'RE INVENTORY
IS VERY MUCH AT RISK.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SLOW-MOVING GOODS RIGHT NOW.
EVERYTHING IS CYCLING THROUGH
SO FAST --
WELL, UNTIL
THE NEXT ONE COMES, RIGHT?
IF KOREA HAS SO MUCH INNOVATION,
WHY WOULDN'T LARGE RETAILERS
THAT MAKE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN SALES IN COSMETICS
NOT HAVE THOSE
IN THEIR STORES?
SO, SEPHORA OF TARGET ACTUALLY
CARRIES A FEW BRANDS.
NOT A LOT --
THEY'VE JUST STARTED.
SO, THEY'RE COMPETITORS NOW.
THEY'RE COMPETITORS, IN A WAY,
BUT THEY ACTUALLY COME TO US
TO SEEK INNOVATION TRENDS
AND IDEAS.
SO YOU'RE THINKING YOU'RE
CONSULTANTS FOR THIS INDUSTRY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE'RE THINKING THAT WE'RE
THE THOUGHT AND TREND LEADERS
WHEN IT COMES TO
K-BEAUTY IN THE U.S.
EXACTLY.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE SCALE
THAT YOUR COMPETITORS,
THE RETAILERS, HAVE.
WELL, OF COURSE.
THEY'RE A START-UP.
WHY CAN'T THEY HIRE
SOME GREAT TALENT?
WELL, ANYBODY CAN DO IT.
I MEAN, ANYBODY
COULD BE A DISTRIBUTOR.
YEAH, BUT HOW MANY
SARAH AND CHRISTINE'S
ARE THERE OUT THERE?
THANK YOU, MARK.
EXACTLY. THANK YOU.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE WANTED TO BRING THAT UP.
WE ALSO PROVIDE EDUCATION
AND TRANSLATION.
NOT ALL DISTRIBUTORS
DO THAT.
YOU KNOW,
THE -- THE -- THE ONE SECTOR,
THE ONE INDUSTRY
THAT'S MAINTAINED ITS MARGINS
FOR 100 YEARS
IS THE COSMETIC BUSINESS.
YES.
I'M JUST
CHOKING ON THIS VALUATION.
OKAY, WELL, YOU DIGEST THAT.
LET ME SPEAK, IF YOU DON'T MIND.
[ LAUGHS ]
I LOVE THE DISTRIBUTOR SPACE
BECAUSE YOU'RE A MIDDLE MAN.
IT'S CHEAPER.
YOU CAN GROW FASTER.
BUT YOUR NUMBERS ARE NUTS.
YOU SHOULD HAVE
COME IN CHEAPER
AND OFFERED
A LOT MORE STOCK, I THINK.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO CONSIDER THAT VALUATION
FOR A HIGHER EQUITY SHARE?
PERCENTAGE.
WELL, A LOT OF --
I'D HAVE TO ASK A LOT OF STOCK.
HOW MUCH?
I GUESS I'D GIVE YOU
$425,000 FOR 40%.
[ LAUGHS ]
BARBARA'S NOT CRAZY,
'CAUSE I WAS GONNA OFFER YOU
$425,000 FOR 50%.
Herjavec: I THINK YOU GUYS
ARE THE REAL DEAL.
YOU'RE SMART.
YOU HAVE CREDIBILITY.
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE INDUSTRY.
IT'S A PURE EXECUTION BUSINESS,
SO I GOT TO BUY YOU.
I'LL MAKE A BET
ON THE TWO OF YOU,
BUT NOT AT 10%.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $425,000 FOR 30%.
I THINK THE BUSINESS IS WORTH
ROUGHLY $1 MILLION TODAY.
BUT WE'RE PROJECTED TO DO
$1 MILLION
JUST IN OUR REVENUE THIS YEAR.
NEXT YEAR, OUR PROJECTION
IS OVER $3 MILLION
AND IN THE NEXT THREE YEARS --
BUT THE KEY WORD THERE
IS "PROJECT".
GUYS, WHAT YOU NEED --
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I THINK.
OKAY.
SURE.
I'VE BEEN IN
THE BEAUTY-RETAIL INDUSTRY
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
IT'S A GREAT BUSINESS,
BUT IT'S A VERY COMPETITIVE
BUSINESS, AS YOU KNOW.
OF COURSE.
ABSOLUTELY.
ONE OF THE MOST BRUTAL,
RIGHT?
SO, FOR ME, IT'S NOT THE RIGHT
INVESTMENT, SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
THANK YOU.
GUYS, YOU HAVEN'T GOTTEN
VERY FAR WITH DIGITAL CONTENT,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
YOU'RE HERE.
WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO ON THAT.
RIGHT, YOU HAVEN'T
DONE BUBKIS YET.
BUT THAT'S WHERE THE VIRAL
OPPORTUNITIES SHOULD COME UP.
WE REALLY NEED YOUR HELP,
ACTUALLY.
WE'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THAT EXPERTISE
IN THE DIGITAL SPACE.
CHRISTINE, WHAT IS
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF EQUITY
YOU'D BE WILLING TO PART WITH
FOR $425,000?
MAYBE WE CAN GET TO
AN ANSWER VERY QUICKLY,
BECAUSE NOBODY'S WILLING
TO GIVE YOU THE DEAL AT 10%.
WELL, MARK MIGHT.
NO, I WOULDN'T DO IT --
I WOULDN'T DO IT AT 10%.
WELL, WHAT WOULD YOU DO,
MARK?
YEAH, WE'D LOVE
TO HEAR FROM YOU, MARK.
[ LAUGHS ]
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I DON'T KNOW.
O'Leary:
MARK, THROW IT OUT THERE.
WELL, THEN GO OUT!
YEAH, REALLY.
SARAH AND CHRISTINE HAVE
THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR KOREAN BEAUTY BUSINESS
GLOW RECIPE,
BUT MARK MAY ALSO BE INTERESTED.
YOU HAVE BARBARA, WHO OFFERED
YOU $425,000 FOR 40%.
YOU HAVE ROBERT, WHO OFFERED YOU
$425,000 FOR 30%.
WELL, WHAT ABOUT MINE?
AND, KEVIN,
WHAT DID YOU OFFER?
WELL, I ALSO WANT A PREMIUM
FOR WHO I AM, MR. WONDERFUL,
SO I'M ASKING FOR AN EXTRA 10%,
BECAUSE I AM MR. WONDERFUL.
OF COURSE.
$425,000 FOR 50%.
FOR 50%
AND, MARK, MAY I ASK
IF YOU HAVE AN OFFER, TOO?
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU COULD LOSE
ANY ONE OF THOSE OFFERS
ANY MINUTE NOW.
I MEAN, AS YOU'RE TALKING,
THEY COULD DROP OUT.
I'M USUALLY
SO DECISIVE ON WHAT I SEE,
AND I JUST DON'T KNOW --
I MEAN I WORK WITH
A LOT OF KOREAN COMPANIES,
SO I'M THINKING,
"OKAY,
THERE'S AN ANGLE THERE."
BUT I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT I DON'T KNOW
ON THIS PARTICULAR CASE,
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY, CHRISTINE.
OKAY NOW.
SO, ROBERT, WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO CONSIDER...
18%?
CHRISTINE,
WOULD YOU DO IT AT 25%?
ROBERT, WOULD YOU DO IT
AT 22.5%? [ CHUCKLES ]
IF IT'S WORTH 25%,
IT'S WORTH 22.5%.
I'VE COME DOWN.
I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
I'D LOVE
TO BE INVOLVED WITH YOU.
I WOULD DEFINITELY DO IT
AT 25%.
[ WHISPERS INDISTINCTLY ]
ROBERT AND MARK, IF YOU WOULD
COME TOGETHER AT 25%,
WE WOULD BE WILLING
TO TAKE THE OFFER.
GUESS THEY DON'T LIKE US.
IF YOU WANT ANOTHER SHARK,
THEN THE AMOUNT OF EQUITY'S
GOT TO GO UP
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
I'M HAPPY TO DO A DEAL ALONE --
$425,000 FOR 25%.
I DON'T THINK I NEED
ANOTHER SHARK.
I'VE GOT THE TECH, IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
[ SPEAKING KOREAN ]
THEY CAN JUST TALK IN KOREAN.
WE WON'T UNDERSTAND THEM.
[ LAUGHS ]
YES.
THANK YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
YOUR OFFER.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
OH, MY, YOU GUYS.
OH, THANK YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH,
ROBERT.
YEAH. THANK YOU.
GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
SO, SHARKS,
WE WANTED TO JUST
BRIEFLY TELL YOU "THANK YOU"
IN KOREAN.
GOMAPSEUMNIDA.
GOMAPSEUMNIDA?
YES.
HOW DO I SAY,
"SCREW YOU, KEVIN" IN KOREAN.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, NO.
OH.
PLEASE, DON'T BE RUDE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Cuban:
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
THEY'RE NICE GIRLS.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA SAY IT.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
OH, MY GOD!
OUR MINDS ARE BLOWN. WE'RE SO
EXCITED FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
WE'RE -- WE HAVE A DEAL
WITH A SHARK!
WITH ROBERT!
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
PAT YATES STRUCK A DEAL
WITH ROBERT HERJAVEC FOR HIS
SLIPPER COMPANY, HAPPY FEET.
$375,000...
WAIT.
...25%,
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WAIT.
DONE.
LET'S SEE
WHAT HE'S UP TO NOW.
Yates: MORNING, MICHELLE.
MORNING, TIFF.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH ROBERT
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF,
AND AMAZING THINGS ARE HAPPENING
FOR HAPPY FEET.
THE YEAR BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
I HAD $2.65 MILLION IN SALES.
SINCE "SHARK TANK," I'VE DONE
$4.2 MILLION IN SALES.
BOOM.
AND THE SITE'S LIVE.
[ CHEERING ]
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROJECTS
WE'VE UNDERTAKEN
IS A MASSIVE OVERHAUL
OF THE HAPPY FEET WEBSITE.
WE'VE MOVED INTO A NEW OFFICE
AND HAVE 16 EMPLOYEES.
BUT THE MOST EXCITING THING
IS DreamWorks ANIMATION
HAS REACHED OUT TO US ABOUT
A LICENSING OPPORTUNITY.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A GREAT WAY
TO GET HAPPY FEET INTO RETAIL,
BUT I REALLY WANT TO HEAR
ROBERT'S TAKE ON IT, AS WELL.
HEY, ROBERT.
HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
Herjavec: LICENSING DEALS
ARE A PERFECT FIT
FOR A COMPANY LIKE HAPPY FEET.
IT'S LIKE RENTING
SOMEBODY ELSE'S BRAND
AND TAKING IT OUT
INTO THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE NEW MOVIES
COMING OUT ALL THE TIME,
THEY HAVE NEW CHARACTERS.
AND WHO WOULDN'T LOVE
A SHREK SLIPPER?
THE CHALLENGE WITH ANY PRODUCT
IS DISTRIBUTION, TYPICALLY.
IF WE CAN PIVOT INTO CREATING
CHARACTERS THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS,
THIS COULD BE
A TENS-OF-MILLIONS-OF-DOLLARS
BUSINESS.
ENOUGH TALKING.
LET'S GO DO IT.
I LOVE IT. LET'S DO IT.
ALL RIGHT.
Yates:
MAKING A DEAL ON "SHARK TANK"
HAS COMPLETELY CHANGED
MY BUSINESS.
WITH ROBERT ON BOARD, WE HAVE
A LEVEL OF CREDIBILITY NOW
THAT WE COULD'VE NEVER ACHIEVED
WITHOUT HIM.
WE'RE NOT JUST SELLING SLIPPERS,
WE'RE SELLING FUN.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
MAKING EVEN MORE PEOPLE HAPPY
WITH HAPPY FEET.
All: HAPPY FEET!
[ CHEERING ]
MY NAME IS SARAH OLIVER,
I LIVE IN
MILL VALLEY, CALIFORNIA.
GROWING UP, MY MOM
AND MY GREAT AUNT TAUGHT ME
HOW TO KNIT,
AND I WAS INSTANTLY HOOKED.
ONE YEAR FOR THE HOLIDAYS,
I DECIDED TO KNIT
EVERY WOMAN IN MY FAMILY A GIFT.
THEY LOVED IT,
AND I STARTED GETTING REQUESTS.
IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT I HAD
A BUSINESS ON MY HANDS.
AND AS IT GREW,
I NEEDED TO BRING ON SOME HELP.
YOU MIGHT KNOW THEM
AS SENIOR CITIZENS,
BUT I CALL THEM
"THE PURLETTES PLUS ONE"
I'M 88 YEARS OLD.
I'M 79 YEARS OLD.
I'M 94, AND I LOVE KNITTING.
Richards: YOU'RE NEVER TOO OLD
TO KEEP WORKING.
IT JUST KEEPS YOU YOUNG.
Oliver: THE PURLETTES ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR BUSINESS.
IT'S THEIR PASSION
AND NIMBLE FINGERS
THAT MAKE THIS COMPANY
SO WONDERFUL.
YEP, THEY'RE ALL HAND-KNIT.
PEOPLE LOVE MY PRODUCT.
AND ONCE THEY HEAR
THE STORY BEHIND IT,
THEY FEEL EVEN MORE CONNECTED.
I HOPE THE SHARKS SEE THE VALUE
IN MY BUSINESS MODEL
SO THAT I CAN CONTINUE TO BRING
JOY TO THE PURLETTES PLUS ONE.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS SARAH OLIVER.
I'M THE FOUNDER AND OWNER
OF SARAH OLIVER HANDBAGS.
I'M ASKING FOR $250,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
IT'S NO SECRET
THAT WOMEN LOVE HANDBAGS.
BUT HOW MANY OF THOSE BAGS
COME WITH MEANING?
IF ONLY THE HANDS THAT MADE
THOSE BAGS COULD TALK.
WELL, NOW THEY CAN.
SARAH OLIVER HANDBAGS
ARE ALL HAND-KNIT
WITH LOVE AND CARE
IN THE U.S.A.,
AND I'VE DEVELOPED A UNIQUE
MANUFACTURING MODEL
NEVER USED BEFORE.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
THE PURLETTES PLUS ONE.
MY NAME IS ELLIE LEVA --
REALLY ELEANOR.
I'M DAPHNEY CAMPBELL.
KATHERINE GAINEY.
MY NAME IS HECTOR RICHARDS.
I'M THE "ONE" OF
THE PURLETTES PLUS ONE.
TO BE INVOLVED IN A COMPANY
AT 83 1/2
IS LIKE HAVING
YOUR WISH COME TRUE.
IT'S THE JOY OF MY ELDER LIFE.
I'VE JUST LOVED IT,
AND I'M THRILLED
WITH SARAH'S SUCCESS.
I LOVE IT.
I LOVE HER, AND I LOVE
THE KNITTING. [ LAUGHS ]
AND I LOVE THE PURLETTES.
Cuban: AWW.
WHAT A SURPRISE THAT WAS.
THEY'RE MY HEROES..
THIS BUSINESS
IS A VERY BIG PART OF ME.
I JUST LOVE WORKING
WITH THESE SENIORS.
WITH YOUR INVESTMENT,
YOUR ADVICE, AND YOUR CONTACTS,
WE CAN BUILD THIS
REVOLUTIONARY BUSINESS TOGETHER.
SARAH, IS THIS A CHARITY
OR IS IT A BUSINESS
OR A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH?
THIS IS A BUSINESS.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY A BUSINESS.
CAN WE SEE THE BAGS?
SURE.
OH, I FORGOT.
BUT WAIT, THERE'S MORE!
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, THIS IS FOR YOU
TO LOOK AT.
THANK YOU, SARAH.
THAT'S OUR GOLD WRISTLET.
OH, HERE.
OH, BLACK. OOH.
AND, YEP,
THAT'S OUR CROSSBODY.
NICE.
GREEN FOR YOU.
OH, THANK YOU.
MY FAVORITE COLOR
IS IT KNIT OR WOOL?
IT'S KNIT.
THE "O" ON THERE
IS ACTUALLY A BROOCH.
IT'S REMOVABLE.
IT MEANS IT COMES OFF,
AND YOU CAN WEAR IT AS A PIN?
EXACTLY.
SO, I FOUND A CARD IN MINE
THAT SAYS
"MY NAME IS DAPHNEY,
AND THIS IS MY STORY."
DID DAPHNEY KNIT MY BAG?
DAPHNEY KNIT YOUR BAG.
SHE'S 92.
SHE'S AMAZING.
THEY'RE ALL INCREDIBLE.
WHAT DID YOU PAY ESTHER
TO MAKE MY BAG?
I PAID HER $17.
IS THAT RIGHT?
O'Leary: AND THEY'RE
ALL DOING IT WILLINGLY.
THIS ISN'T
A GERIATRIC SWEATSHOP, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHS ] NO.
I KNEW YOU WERE GONNA ASK THAT,
MR. WONDERFUL.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
NO, ACTUALLY I'M THE ONE
WHO GETS IN TROUBLE.
IF I DON'T BRING ENOUGH WOOL,
THEY LOOK AT ME
AND THEY'RE LIKE, "WHAT?
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR ME
THIS WEEK.
WHAT AM I GONNA DO ALL WEEK?"
THEY'RE REALLY QUITE NICE.
WHAT DOES IT COST TO MAKE ONE?
AND WHAT DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
SO, THE RESORT
IS OUR BEST SELLER.
IT COST $47 TO MAKE.
THEY RETAIL FOR $225.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
SO FAR?
UM, OUR LIFETIME SALES
ARE $1.9 MILLION.
OH, THAT'S COOL.
LAST YEAR WAS $360,000.
SO, SARAH,
WHAT DO YOU REALLY NEED?
YEAH.
WHAT I NEED
IS MONEY -- WORKING CAPITAL.
RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE 90 ACCOUNTS --
90 STORE ACCOUNTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SO, THERE'S
NO ONLINE BUSINESS HERE?
I DO SELL THEM ONLINE,
TOO.
BECAUSE I THINK
THE OPPORTUNITY
IS TO TELL THE STORIES
OF THESE WOMEN.
WHERE DID YOU FIND
THOSE WOMEN?
I'M SO CURIOUS.
SO, WHEN MY KIDS
WERE LITTLE,
THERE'S THIS AMAZING
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY --
THE REDWOODS SENIOR COMMUNITY
IN MILL VALLEY.
I USED TO BRING MY KIDS THERE.
THAT'S SUCH A GREAT IDEA.
SO FAST-FORWARD TO WHEN
I WANTED TO SCALE PRODUCTION,
IT'S OBVIOUS.
WHO KNITS?
WHO DO I FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH?
I DON'T WANT TO GO OVERSEAS.
AND SO IT JUST --
IT WAS A NATURAL --
LIKE, RIGHT AROUND --
SO IMPRESSIVE.
I DIDN'T THINK OF
THE MARKETING BACK THEN.
YEAH, COULD YOU IMAGINE --
IF I GO TO YOUR WEBSITE,
CAN A SEE A LOT OF --
CAN I MEET DAPHNEY?
YOU ABSOLUTELY CAN.
WE HAVE VIDEOS.
THAT'S AWESOME.
AND HOW MANY PURSES CAN
A PURLETTE MAKE IN A DAY?
WELL, A PURLETTE CAN MAKE
ABOUT THREE IN A -- IN A WEEK,
WE KIND OF AVERAGE.
SO, YOU KNOW,
I JUST HAVE TO SAY,
IT'S SO TOUCHING TO ME --
ACTUALLY
BROUGHT A TEAR TO MY EYE --
BECAUSE I THINK THAT, OFTEN,
WE DON'T VALUE ENOUGH
OUR ELDERLY IN SOCIETY,
YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND YOU HAVE GIVEN THEM ALL
SOMETHING TO BE EXCITED ABOUT.
NO QUESTION.
THEY'RE FEELING
A PART OF SOMETHING.
RIGHT.
AND THEY NEED TO
CONSTANTLY FEEL
IMPORTANT AND VALUED
AND PART --
I GET THAT FEEDBACK
ALL THE TIME.
I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
AND I WOULD LIKE --
IF MY FELLOW SHARKS WOULD LIKE
TO BE IN ON THE OFFER -- I'D
LIKE FOR US ALL TO BE IN ON IT,
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THINK
THAT I WOULD LOVE FOR ALL OF US
TO HELP MAKE THIS
A STATEMENT.
OH.
WHAT'S THE OFFER?
SO MY OFFER IS
$250,000...
MM-HMM.
...FOR 25%.
OKAY.
EACH SHARK GETS 5%.
I'M IN.
LET ME TELL YOU
WHY I'M IN.
OKAY, ROBERT.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT CAUSE,
MM-HMM.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT LORI SAID.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRODUCT
THAT TOUCHES THE HEARTS
OF CONSUMERS, IT BLOWS UP.
MM-HMM.
I THINK PEOPLE AT HOME
AND ACROSS AMERICA
ARE GONNA JUST GO BOOM
TO THE WEBSITE.
RIGHT. I HOPE SO.
I REALLY DO.
AND I HOPE THAT WE GET
A MILLION MORE PURLETTES.
O'Leary: YEAH, BUT I...
I'D LIKE TO ASK A FEW MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT NUMBERS
BEFORE I --
I DECIDE IF I'M GONNA INVEST...
ABSOLUTELY.
...BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
THE CHARITY TANK TO ME.
NO. ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I'M NOT IN IT
FOR THE CHARITY.
YOU SOMETIMES -- IT'S NOT ALWAYS
ABOUT THE MONEY.
LORI,
PICK YOUR OWN CHARITIES.
LISTEN, I'M SORRY. I DO.
I GIVE A LOT TO CHARITY.
IT IS ABOUT THE MONEY.
BUT THIS IS
AN INVESTMENT FOR ME.
HOW DO I FIND PURLETTES
THAT DO FOUR A WEEK?
SO, RIGHT NOW, I WORK WITH
TWO RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE ABOUT 30 KNITTERS.
THEY CAN MAKE ABOUT
4,000 BAGS A YEAR.
THAT TRANSLATES
TO ABOUT $900,000.
MY GOAL IN THE NEXT
TWO TO THREE YEARS
IS TO GO OUT TO ABOUT
FIVE RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES
WHO ALREADY WANT ME.
SARAH, WE -- LOOK.
LORI MADE A GREAT OFFER.
I'M HAPPY TO GO IN WITH HER.
WAIT A SECOND.
NO, SHE DIDN'T.
SHE MADE AN OFFER
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US.
YEAH, NO, IT'S OKAY.
YOU DON'T NEED TO GO IN ON IT.
I WANTED TO EXTEND IT
TO EVERYBODY.
OKAY.
SARAH, THIS FALLS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN A COTTAGE INDUSTRY
AND A CHARITY IN MY MIND.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN INVESTABLE
BUSINESS, SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU, THOUGH.
SARAH, I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS GREAT,
BUT IT'S JUST NOT A FIT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Herjavec: I'M HAPPY
TO GO IN WITH LORI.
$250,000.
$125,000 FROM EACH OF US.
OKAY.
25%.
THAT'S -- THAT'S SO FANTASTIC.
IS THAT A YES?
I WOULD SAY YES BEFORE
SOMEONE CHANGES THEIR MIND.
I -- I LOVE IT.
I WANTED TO HEAR
FROM MR. WONDERFUL.
[ SIGHS ]
KEVIN?
OKAY, THE ONLY WAY THIS HAPPENS
IS YOU GO TO 30%,
'CAUSE I WANT 10%.
I DON'T GET UP IN THE MORNING
FOR LESS THAN THAT,
AND I'LL JOIN THEM.
WELL, IS IT IMPORTANT TO YOU
TO HAVE HIM IN?
ALL RIGHT. I'M IN.
I'M IN ON THAT.
I'M SORRY.
EXPLAIN THAT AGAIN.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU'RE GOING BACKWARDS.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
IT'S JUST WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
YOU'RE GOING BACKWARDS.
THIS -- THIS --
IT'S A BUSINESS, OKAY.
ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE YOU'RE PAYING
THE PURLETTES,
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
TO MAKE THIS WORK,
IF ALL OF THIS IS GONNA HAPPEN,
YOU HAVE TO INCREASE
YOUR CAPACITY BY FOUR TIMES.
ALL RIGHT?
CORRECT.
SO...
WHICH YOU WILL.
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME WORK
INVOLVED FROM EACH SHARK.
MM-HMM.
AND I GENERALLY DON'T DO DEALS
FOR LESS THAN 10% EQUITY.
WHY?
IT'S JUST NOT WORTH IT.
MM-HMM.
IF YOU REALLY WANT ME
IN THIS DEAL,
I'LL JOIN THEM
1/3, 1/3, 1/3.
WE'LL GIVE YOU
THE $250,000.
YOU HAVE TO PART
WITH 30%.
I'M OKAY IF YOU JUST
GO WITH THESE TWO GUYS, TOO.
MM-HMM.
BUT I GOT TO HAVE 10%,
SARAH.
SARAH,
I LIKE THAT DEAL BETTER.
I'M FINE WITH THAT DEAL.
YEAH.
SO THAT'S THE 30%?
YEAH,
AND YOU GET THREE SHARKS.
YEAH, AND YOU GET
$250,000 FOR 30%.
BUT I TELL YOU --
LIKE I SAID, YOU SHOULD'VE SAID
YES WHEN YOU HAD THE CHANCE.
YEAH, I THINK I WOULD ACTUALLY
LIKE TO GO WITH LORI AND ROBERT.
WELL, NOW I LIKE
KEVIN'S DEAL BETTER, SARAH.
YOU DO? OKAY.
YEAH.
Greiner: UH-OH.
UH-OH.
Cuban: BOY, THERE'S
A LESSON RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE SHARK TANK.
THAT'S THE SHARK TANK.
WHAT HAPPENED TO CHARITY?
MY GOD. GONE.
OUT THE WINDOW.
I NEVER SAID CHARITY.
WE WANT ALL THE SHARKS.
I THINK IT'S A BUSINESS.
♪♪
SO THAT'S 30%.
UM, I THINK I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
THREE SHARKS ON MY TEAM.
SO. DO YOU ACCEPT OUR OFFER?
I DO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
GOOD.
SO EXCITING.
Cuban:
CONGRATULATIONS, SARAH.
OH, MY GOD.
THE PURLETTES ARE GONNA BE
SO EXCITED.
[ LAUGHS ]
I KNOW THAT THEY'RE --
I'M EXCITED.
OH, MY GOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATS.
YOU BETTER GO
AND SEE SOME PURLETTES.
YOU NEED A LOT MORE.
I KNOW.
MORE THAN YOU CAN IMAGINE.
RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA GET
A LOT OF PURLETTES.
I KNOW IT.
WE ARE.
WE ARE,
AND WE'RE GONNA SELL!
WE ARE.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
WE ARE GONNA MAKE
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAPPY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Corcoran: BYE-BYE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATS, SARAH.
Oliver: THANK YOU.
NOW, GET
THOSE PURLETTES TO WORK!
I WILL!
I'M SO EXCITED.
I JUST CANNOT WAIT
TO LET THE PURLETTES KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE
TEAM BEHIND US
TO GROW THIS COMPANY LIKE CRAZY.
I HOPE TO HIRE SENIORS
EVERYWHERE.
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A HIGH-TECH VERSION
OF A TRAVEL NECESSITY.
HOLA, SHARKS.
I'M GASTON BLANCHET
FROM ARGENTINA,
AND THIS IS MY BEST FRIEND,
JESSE POTASH,
FROM NEW YORK.
OUR COMPANY IS TRUNKSTER,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $1.4 MILLION
IN EXCHANGE FOR 5%.
WOW.
[ O'LEARY CHUCKLES ]
SHARKS, MEET TRUNKSTER,
THE WORLD'S FIRST AND ONLY
ROLL-TOP SUITCASE.
TRUNKSTER'S MINIMALIST
ROLL-TOP DOOR
PROVIDES INSTANT ACCESS
TO YOUR BELONGINGS,
WHETHER IN THE BACK OF A TAXI
OR AT THE CHECK-IN COUNTER,
YOU'RE JUST
A QUICK SLIDE AWAY
FROM YOUR PASSPORT, BOOK,
OR SWEATER.
AND THAT'S
JUST THE BEGINNING.
TRUNKSTER'S LOADED
WITH SMART FEATURES.
WE'VE ENGINEERED
THE WORLD'S FIRST
SELF-CONTAINED HANDLE SCALE,
SO YOU CAN PACK JUST UNDER
THE WEIGHT LIMIT
AND AVOID COSTLY FEES.
SHARKS,
IS THERE ANYTHING WORSE
THAN RUNNING OUT OF POWER
ON THE GO?
WITH TRUNKSTER,
YOU'VE GOT JUICE ALL TO YOURSELF
VIA THE BUILT-IN USB PORTS
POWERED BY A REMOVABLE BATTERY.
AND FORGET ABOUT
LOST-LUGGAGE NIGHTMARES,
'CAUSE TRUNKSTER OFFERS
GLOBAL LOCATION TRACKING
WITH PROXIMITY SENSORS.
TRUNKSTER GIVES YOU
ALL OF THIS,
PLUS IT'S MADE FROM
THE HIGHEST-QUALITY MATERIALS,
USING A PATENT-PENDING
ASSEMBLY PROCESS
FOR LIGHTWEIGHT
AND RIGID DURABILITY.
NOT TO MENTION
HOW SEXY IT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS IS THE BIGGEST
LUGGAGE INNOVATION
SINCE WHEELS WERE ADDED
50 YEARS AGO,
AND WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO ESTABLISH OURSELVES
AS THE GAME-CHANGING
LUGGAGE BRAND WORLDWIDE.
SO, WHO'S IN?
YOU GONNA SHOW US
THE PRODUCT?
JUST TO PREFACE,
THE INSIDES OF THESE --
HOW DO YOU OPEN IT?
OH, YOU CAN JUST PRESS
THIS BUTTON VERY GENTLY...
JUST PULL IT OUT THERE.
...AND IT'LL SLIDE DOWN.
YOU CAN OPEN IT STANDING UP
OR LAYING DOWN,
Greiner: OH.
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF IT.
[ BANGING ]
CAN THIS REALLY
TAKE A HIT?
YEAH.
Potash: SO, YES, THEY CAN
ABSOLUTELY TAKE A HIT.
THEY'VE BEEN TESTED
TO EVERY LUGGAGE STANDARD --
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS.
MAY I SEE HOW MUCH
THAT WEIGHS?
I JUST WANT TO PULL IT.
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
AND JUST SO YOU KNOW, THEY'LL
WEIGH LESS THAN EIGHT POUNDS
WHEN THEY'RE FINISHED.
WHEELS ARE GREAT.
SO, HOW'D YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
I WAS IN A LUGGAGE STORE,
AND I REALIZED,
"LIKE, WOW, EVERY LUGGAGE BRAND
IS THE SAME."
AS A MILLENNIAL, LIKE,
I'D LIKE TO BUY A BRAND
THAT HAS A STORY BEHIND IT,
THAT COMES FROM
GRASSROOTS TRAVELERS.
THERE'S NO BRAND LIKE THIS
IN THE LUGGAGE MARKET.
IT'S SO CORPORATE.
YOU'RE SUCH MILLENNIALS.
YEAH.
YOU ARE!
WELL, NO --
YOU'RE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
IT'S SO CORPORATE."
NO -- BUT, NO --
WELL, IT'S BORING.
IT'S ABOUT TO GET CORPORATE.
YEAH.
$1.4 MILLION FOR 5%?
WHICH ONE OF YOU DO I ABSOLUTELY
TEAR TO PIECES NOW
ON A $28-MILLION-DOLLAR
VALUATION?
ALL RIGHT,
I'LL TAKE THE PAIN FIRST.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?
GASTON,
ARE YOU NOT SELLING THIS YET?
WE ARE PRE-SELLING THIS
BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
IN THE MANUFACTURING PROCESS.
Greiner: KICKSTARTER.
YOU'RE PRE-SELLING, AND YOU HAVE
A $28 MILLION VALUATION?
YES, SIR.
DO YOU SEE ANY PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
NO, BECAUSE --
I'LL EXPLAIN
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET ME EXPLAIN.
EIGHT MONTHS AGO, WE BECAME
THE MOST CROWDFUNDED
TRAVEL CAMPAIGN
IN HISTORY ON KICKSTARTER.
WE RAISED $1.4 MILLION.
WE HIT OUR GOAL IN ONE HOUR.
TO DATE, WE'VE PRE-SOLD
$2 MILLION OF THIS BAG,
WHICH SELLS ITSELF.
WE DIDN'T EVEN ASK
HOW MUCH ONE OF THESE COSTS.
YEAH, SO WE RETAIL THEM
FOR $395,
AND THE COST IS ABOUT
20% OF THAT.
FOR THE SMALL ONE?
EXACTLY.
SO, IT'S A PROTOTYPE,
BUT ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
BOUGHT IN, HAVEN'T TRIED IT.
THESE ARE THE FIRST SAMPLES
OFF THE LINE.
WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE
TO SHIPPING -- UH, NEXT MONTH.
WE HAVE 5,000 UNITS...
TAKES ABOUT FOUR DAYS.
Greiner: THAT ARE BEING MADE.
...THAT ARE ABOUT TO BE
ON THE ASSEMBLY LINE
THAT WILL BE SHIPPED OUT
NEXT MONTH.
SO, WE ACTUALLY --
YOU HAVE A GUY THERE
CHECKING ON THE QUAL--
THE QUANTITY?
WE ACTUALLY LIVE IN CHINA.
WE LIVE IN CHINA.
YOU DO?
YEAH, WE'VE LIVED
FOR MONTHS IN CHINA.
WE'RE BACK NOW.
WE LIVE IN THE FACTORY IN CHINA.
WHY IS IT WORTH
$28 MILLION?
WELL...EXACTLY.
THAT WAS MY FIRST QUESTION.
YOU NEVER ANSWERED.
WE ARE ESTIMATING $3 MILLION
IN SALES THIS YEAR.
SO FAR, WE'VE DONE $2 MILLION.
NEXT YEAR, WE'RE ESTIMATING
ABOUT $9 MILLION IN SALES.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THIS,
FIRST OF ALL,
INTO A BILLION-DOLLAR COMPANY.
AND WE'RE DOING -- WE'RE GONNA
DISRUPT THE LUGGAGE INDUSTRY
THE SAME WAY
THE MATTRESS INDUSTRY
HAS RECENTLY BEEN DISRUPTED.
HOW?
AND THAT'S BY OFFERING
A PREMIUM PRODUCT
AT A SIGNIFICANT DISCOUNT
TO CONSUMERS.
LUGGAGE OF THIS QUALITY --
SO, YOU'RE GONNA SELL
EVERYTHING ONLINE.
DIRECT TO CONSUMERS.
ALL ONLINE.
ALL RIGHT.
LORI, LUGGAGE QUEEN.
IS THIS REVOLUTIONARY?
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT.
VERY CLEVER.
IS IT WORTH $28 MILLION?
NOTHING'S WORTH 28 MILLION.
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER STORY.
YOU GUYS KNOW
IT'S A HUGE ASK.
Blanchet: IT'S A HUGE ASK.
YOU REALIZE THAT.
AND YOU HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN IT
INTO PEOPLE'S HANDS YET.
WELL, HSN REACHED OUT TO US
AND SAID --
BUT YOU'RE PRICING THAT AS
THOUGH IT'S ALREADY HAPPENED.
ASK ME
IF IT'S WORTH $28 MILLION,
AND I'LL TELL YOU.
NO!
I GOT TO TELL YOU.
I THINK THE BUSINESS
IS PROBABLY WORTH
$5 MILLION
TO $8 MILLION TODAY.
MOST.
WOULD YOU MAKE AN OFFER --
BUT IF WE'RE MAKING $3 MILLION
IN OUR FIRST YEAR --
HANG ON. HANG ON.
LET'S GET ANOTHER TAKE.
YOU PUT THAT MONEY IN YOUR
POCKET. THAT'S MONEY YOU MADE.
YOU PUT THAT IN YOUR POCKET,
BUT THAT'S ANECDOTAL, RIGHT?
IT'S ONE-OFF.
YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY TRACK RECORD THERE.
WOULD YOU SELL
30% OF THE COMPANY TO ROBERT
FOR $1.4 MILLION, WHICH REFLECTS
HIS MORE CONSERVATIVE
$5 MILLION VALUATION?
WOULD YOU?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE INTEREST WE'VE SEEN FROM
ALL THE OTHER LUGGAGE COMPANIES
WHO ARE --
WHO ARE RUNNING SCARED
AND INTERESTED IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE CAN GROW THIS
TO $10 MILLION, $20 MILLION.
GUYS, GUYS. IT'S EXCITING.
IT'S EXCITING.
WE'RE REACHING
FOR A BIG SALE.
WE HAVE NEW PRODUCTS
IN THE LINE.
WE WANT TO MAKE THIS
A CAMERA BAG, A PHOTOGRAPHY BAG.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FLEXIBILITY
ON THE 28% --
WE HAVE OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT WE'RE GONNA DEBUT
AND UPSELL ON OUR WEBSITE.
GASTON. GASTON! STOP TALKING!
SILENCE. NO MORE EXCITEMENT.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND OUT...
Herjavec: WHAT'S GOING ON?!
WHEN IN TROUBLE, DANCE.
...ARE YOU GONNA WALK OUT OF
THE SHARK TANK
WITH A DEAL OR NOT?
WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT RIGHT NOW.
NOBODY'S GONNA HIT YOUR BID
AT $28 MILLION. NOBODY.
Gaston: OF COURSE --
OF COURSE
SILENCE!
ARE YOU PREPARED
TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY
ON YOUR $28 MILLION ASK?
♪♪
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN,
BUT THEY QUESTION THE HIGH
VALUATION OF GASTON AND JESSE'S
SMART LUGGAGE COMPANY,
TRUNKSTER.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO HAVE
FLEXIBILITY
ON YOUR $28 MILLION ASK?
THE REMINDS ME, IF I JUST
MAY SHARE A STORY,
THAT IN JANUARY, WE WERE
CHOOSING OUR FACTORY PARTNER,
AND WE WEREN'T QUITE ABLE
TO GET THERE ON THE PRICE.
MY UNCLE, WHO'S A BUSINESSMAN,
HE TOLD ME TO SAY THIS --
"LISTEN" --
HE'S FROM LONG ISLAND --
"LISTEN, SOMEBODY'S GONNA
MANUFACTURE TRUNKSTER.
EITHER IT'S GONNA BE YOU
OR IT ISN'T.
WHOEVER IT IS, THAT PERSON'S
GONNA MAKE A LOT OF MONEY."
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WAS TRUE
THEN, AND IT'S TRUE NOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
OUR FACTORY PARTNER
IS MAKING A LOT OF MONEY.
JESSE, YOU'RE SAYING
YOU DON'T NEED US?
I ASKED YOU A QUESTION,
AND YOU CAME BACK WITH A STORY.
NO, NO, NO. I WILL SAY TO THAT,
WE'RE REASONABLE.
WE'RE WILLING TO NEGOTIATE.
WE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A BUSINESS,
AND WE WANT
THE RIGHT PARTNER.
♪♪
HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN CASH
DID YOU GUYS PUT IN?
WE SPENT $5,000 TO LAUNCH
THE KICKSTARTER CAMPAIGN,
AND THAT'S ALL THE MONEY
WE'VE INVESTED.
YEAH, WE REALLY --
YOU HAVEN'T
SHIPPED ANYTHING YET.
YOU'RE $5,000
IS WORTH $28 MILLION.
I'M SO LUCKY TO BE HERE.
Herjavec: THAT'S GREAT
WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S A GREAT RETURN.
WELL, ALSO, NO. WE SHOULD SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT THE PRODUCT --
THAT OUR PRODUCT HAS
THREE THINGS
THAT VERY FEW PRODUCTS HAVE
IN COMBINATION.
YOU DON'T NEED
TO SELL ANYMORE.
LISTEN, EVERYBODY AGREES
IT'S INTERESTING.
AND EVEN LORI,
QUEEN OF LUGGAGE --
NO, NO. I'M GONNA -- IF I COULD
BE THE EXCEPTION ON THE PRODUCT.
OH, REALLY?
ARE YOU GONNA POO-POO ON IT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
I FIND
A COUPLE OF THINGS WRONG.
ONE, IT'S VERY SLEEK,
BUT IT'S EXTREMELY MASCULINE.
PRODUCT LINE EXPANSION.
WE'RE THINKING NEW COLORS.
IT WOULDN'T BE A PRODUCT THAT
I WOULD PICK OUT IN A STORE.
Greiner: [ CHUCKLES ] PINK.
YOU'RE DOING OTHERS, BUT I'M
JUDGING BY THIS PROTOTYPE.
SURE.
YES.
OKAY, SECONDLY, I
THINK IT'S TOO HEAVY,
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT
MOST PEOPLE LIKE SOFT LUGGAGE,
NOT HARD LUGGAGE.
AND, LASTLY, YOU HAVEN'T HAD
YOUR CONSUMER BASE TEST IT OUT.
THEY HAVEN'T RECEIVED IT YET.
SO YOU'RE ASKING US TO INVEST
A LOT OF MONEY
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO FEEDBACK
FROM THE GUY WHO'S GONNA USE IT.
WELL, WE HAVE HAD PEOPLE
TEST IT -- NOT EVERYBODY.
THE PRODUCT TESTERS CAME BACK
WITH REALLY POSITIVE REVIEWS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THERE ARE SO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS, BUT, MAGICALLY,
THE TWO OF YOU HAVE CONVINCED ME
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING THERE.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $1.4 MILLION FOR 30%.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND THAT'S A LEGITIMATE OFFER.
MARK CAN LAUGH ALL HE WANTS.
HE'S NOT MAKING AN OFFER.
THAT'S THE OFFER I SEE, BECAUSE
OF ALL THE UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
THIS ISN'T AN INVESTMENT,
WE'RE GOING ON A TRIP TOGETHER.
AND WHEN WE GO
ON THIS TRIP TOGETHER,
WE'RE GONNA LEARN A LOT.
IN THE SUITCASE!
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
O'Leary: BASICALLY,
ROBERT'S COMPUTING A VALUE
OF $5 MILLION ON THE DEAL.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S SAYING,
AND I THINK IT'S FAIR.
YOU KNOW, IN FACT, I'LL JOIN HIM
IF HE WANTS A PARTNER.
I LIKE YOU GUYS,
I'LL DO THAT DEAL.
I'LL GO 50/50 IF HE WANTS TO
MITIGATE HIS RISK A LITTLE BIT.
KEVIN,
I APPRECIATE THE OFFER.
I DON'T WANT KEVIN
TO GO ON THIS TRIP WITH ME,
BECAUSE THERE ARE COUNTRIES
KEVIN'S NOT ALLOWED TO GO INTO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, I WILL MAKE
THE SAME OFFER,
EXCEPT I WANT 37%.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE...
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THEY'LL TAKE THAT.
I'M BEING JUST AS LUDICROUS
AS YOU ARE.
YOUR VALUATION'S INSANE.
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR, MAYBE,
IF THERE WAS ANYTHING ELSE.
COULD WE HEAR OTHER OFFERS?
I'M SITTING HERE THINKING ABOUT
THE RISK, RIGHT?
LOSING MONEY.
ON THE ONE HAND,
I DO THINK THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF THAT CAN BE DONE
WITH IT, RIGHT?
I HAVE LICENSING CONNECTIONS.
I KNOW THIS WORLD VERY WELL.
BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE,
SAY I GIVE YOU THE MONEY
AND SOMETHING
GOES WRONG WITH IT, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T ANTICIPATE IT,
BUT IT COULD HAPPEN.
SO I WOULD GIVE YOU
THE $1.4 MILLION
TO FUND PURCHASE ORDERS --
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID YOU
NEEDED...
HOW MUCH EQUITY DO YOU WANT?
...AT 15%.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR IF MARK
MAYBE HAS SOMETHING TO SAY.
THE PRODUCT'S INTERESTING.
I SEE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
NOW I WANT YOU TO PUT YOURSELF
IN OUR SHOES.
HOW MUCH SHOULD I GET BACK,
AND WHEN?
WE EXPECT TO BE MAKING
$6 MILLION IN NEXT YEAR.
OKAY, JUST SIMPLE QUESTION.
WE CAN PAY YOU BACK
NEXT YEAR.
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
BUT I DON'T WANT JUST
$1 MILLION BACK.
ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT?
WE'RE AIMING TO MAKE
A BILLION-DOLLAR COMPANY.
YOU HAVE US WORKING 24/7 --
Corcoran:
YOU HAVEN'T ANSWERED HIM.
GUYS, GUYS,
SHH, SHH, SHH, SHH.
[ INHALES DEEPLY ]
IN YOUR MIND, THERE'S THESE
BIG NUMBERS YOU CAN PAY BACK.
BUT WHEN WE DO THE MATH
BASED OFF THE EQUITY
YOU'RE OFFERING US,
THE NUMBERS DON'T CALCULATE
TO BIG NUMBERS.
IF YOU MAKE, YOU KNOW,
$20 MILLION NEXT YEAR,
WHAT'S 5% OF $20 MILLION?
JUST $1 MILLION DOLLARS.
RIGHT?
SEE, YOU DIDN'T LOOK AT IT
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
GENTLEMEN, I ALWAYS LOVE MARK
MORE THAN ANYONE ON THE PANEL,
'CAUSE HE'S GOT THE MOST BUCKS,
BUT LET ME TELL YOU,
LORI IS THE BEST PARTNER.
WOULD IT BE AN OPTION
TO WORK TOGETHER?
I WOULD NEGOTIATE.
WELL, MAY WE TAKE
JUST ONE MOMENT SPEAK?
YEAH, PLEASE DO. PLEASE DO.
NOT A BAD IDEA.
THANK YOU.
♪♪
I'M COMFORTABLE
TO GIVE 10%.
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH TWO SHARKS
HELPING US...
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
MARK AND LORI, WE WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER YOU 5% OF TRUNKSTER
FOR $1.4 MILLION.
WE WILL ALSO PAY YOU BACK
THE FULL $1.4 MILLION
WITHIN 24 MONTHS.
AND IF WE DON'T PAY YOU BACK
WITHIN THAT TIMEFRAME,
WE WILL DOUBLE
YOUR EQUITY STAKE TO 10%
AND WE WILL OFFER YOU
$1 IN PERPETUITY
STARTING FROM WHEN THE --
WHEN THE MONEY IS PAID BACK.
ALL RIGHT,
THAT'S YOUR OFFER.
MARK, LORI,
WHAT DO YOU GOT?
I WOULD TAKE THAT DEAL.
YEAH,
WE'LL TAKE THAT DEAL.
WELL, HANG ON.
LOVE IT!
ARE YOU GUYS SPLITTING IT,
MARK?
YEAH, WE'LL SPLIT IT.
Gaston: WOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
I DID NOT SEE THIS COMING.
YOU CAME IN HERE KNOWING THAT,
DIDN'T YOU?
YOU KNEW IT.
I KNOW.
YEAH, DO A LITTLE BUM-BUM-BUM.
THANK YOU GUYS,
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT, WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR OFFER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANKS, GUYS.
OH, MY GOSH.
IF YOU GET PAID BACK
YOUR MONEY
OVER AN INDEFINITE
PERIOD OF TIME,
WELL,
THAT'S NOT VERY ENTICING.
TO KNOW THAT IN TWO YEARS,
YOU'LL DEFINITELY
HAVE THAT MONEY BACK
OR THERE'S A PENALTY,
THEN THAT MAKES US WORK HARDER
AND IT MAKES THEM
MORE SECURE.